Hey Thoughty2 here, let's take a look at what's
going on in Syria.
Many north African and middle eastern countries
are ruled by an iron fist; governments that
pretend to be democracies but display strong
dictatorship qualities and oppress change.
In recent years there has been a sudden influx
of mass demonstrations in these arab countries,
attempting to overthrow their corrupt rulers.
It's called the "Arab Spring" and it was all
started in Tunisia in 2010, by a single fruit
and vegetable seller named Mohamed Bouazizi
after he set himself on fire in protest of
the government.
The Tunisian Revolution subsequently inspired
other Arab nations across North Africa and
the Middle East to protest, notably Egypt.
Syria is the latest to jump on the revolutionary
bandwagon.
Syria has been ruled by the same Syrian family,
the Assads, since 1971.
Their political party is the Ba'ath party.
The current Syrian President Bashar al-Assad
has been in power since 2000.
In the last referendum, in 2007, Bashar al-Assad
was the only candidate, securing his presidency
for another seven year term.
Seems fair.
Sick of the Assad's tight regime, on the 15th
March 2011, Syrian civilians started their
own Arab Spring protest, which quickly gained
momentum and evolved into the Syrian civil
war.
In July 2011 the Free Syrian Army was formed,
an umbrella group representing the Syrian
rebels.
In April 2011 the Syrian Government's Army
was deployed to stop the uprising in its tracks.
Soldiers fired on demonstrators in towns and
cities across the country.
After months of military siege the protestors
got their hands on weapons of their own and
started a full scale armed rebellion consisting
of defected soldiers and civilian volunteers.
Syrian Allies Russia and Iran supply the government
with weapons, whilst Qatar and Saudi Arabia
provide the rebels with their weaponry.
The death toll has now surpassed 100,000,
half of which are civilians, including both
rebels and innocent bystanders.
The other half are Syrian Army soldiers and
1,000 government officials.
1.8 Million Syrians have fled the country
to escape the violence.
Tens of thousands of protestors have been
imprisoned and there are widespread reports
of torture in the nation's prisons.
The Syrian government and protestors have
both been accused of severe human rights abuse.
However the United Nation's investigations
have concluded that the Syrian government's
human rights abuse has been far greater.
But the rebel's aren't exactly saints either.
Certain Syrian rebel groups have pledged loyalty
to al-Qaeda and beheaded numerous Christians.
In January 2012 the Syrian army started to
use large-scale artillery and tanks against
the rebel army which led to many civilian
homes being destroyed because of indiscriminate
shelling.
By July 2012 the fighting had spread across
the whole country and the International Committee
of the Red Cross declared the conflict a civil
war.
The fighting focussed on Syria's capital city,
Damascus.
By late July the government managed to push
back the rebel forces in Damascus and the
focus of the war shifted to the city Aleppo.
A year later and the bulk of the Syrian civil
war still revolves around Aleppo.
So what's the latest news on the Syria convict?
The rebels and Western governments have accused
the Syrian government of using chemical weapons
in attacks that killed more than 1,429 people
near Damascus, 426 of which were children.
One of the bombs was dropped onto a school
playground.
The use of chemical weapons is strictly outlawed
by international law.
The Syrian government have said the rebels
were behind the chemical attacks, however
according to the US government, the rockets
were only launched from government controlled
areas and only aimed towards opposition controlled
areas.
On the 30th August British prime minister
David Cameron was defeated in the House of
Commons in a vote to join the US in strikes
against Syria, in order to deter the use of
chemical weapons.
Therefore Britain will not be involved in
any military action in Syria.
The US is a bit miffed with this decision
but they have said they will continue to consult
with the UK, one of their closest allies.
Obama has said the US will be responding to
the use of chemical weapons in Syria, but
he stated there will be no "boots on the ground".
In other words...
Many skeptics are against the use of military
action in Syria, fearing it may be a repeat
of Iraq.
60% of the United States public says the US
government should not take military action
against Syria.
Many fear such an attack could lead to World
War 3.
Syria has said it will use "all means available"
to defend itself if the United States attacks.
Which could include terror attacks in the
US itself.
Russia have sent their most advanced anti-ship
missiles to Syria.
If one of those sinks a US vessel it would
be sure to escalate matters to a whole new
level.
There is a very good chance that if the US
attacks Syria, Syria will attack Israel.
Israel have said it would respond to any attack
"forcefully", which would surely spell disaster.
Iran's closest ally is Syria and Iran aren't
going to take an attack against Syria lightly.
Furthermore an attack against Syria will seriously
damage the United State's relationship with
Russia.
All of these factors and many more could easily
contribute to the start of the next World
War.
The information in this video is not necessarily
the opinions of myself or anyone associated
with Thoughty2.
I only seek to present the news as it has
been reported, in a more approachable format.
I hope you enjoyed this video, let me know
in the comments if you would like me to do
more videos related to current affairs, such
as this.
Thanks for watching.
Until next time.